on the 26th of February 2015 the
militant group known as Islamic state
posted a video online showing the
destruction of Antiquities in and around
the city of Mosul in northern Iraq
here we see the destruction at Nimrod
palace just outside Mosul we're in a
Syrian winged bull from the ninth
century BC is being destroyed with a
pneumatic drill Molinaro sort of like
sallallaahu anyway the man in the video
is saying these Bruins behind me they
are idols and statues that people used
to worship instead of Allah we were
ordered by our prophet to take down
idols and destroy them videos of this
destruction and the resulting loss of
cultural heritage and shared history
caused shock and grief
to PhD students decided to do something
about it
welcome to the virtual Mosul Museum The
Economist built this place to showcase
the work of project Mosul a cutting-edge
heritage project founded by Matthew
Vincente and chance koknal the two
co-founders have been collecting images
of lost artifacts from the public and
using a technique called photogrammetry
to combine them into 3d models
volunteers from all over the world have
helped digitally reconstruct what has
been destroyed and thus offer the Past a
future the cultural Museum of Mosul was
established in 1952 it was the second
largest museum in Iraq and contained
approximately 2,200 items in four halls
we've built virtual versions of all the
halls but on today's tour will focus on
two that are of particular interest here
we are in the Hat Ron Hall this ancient
statue of a priest was reconstructed by
a volunteer nicknamed a6 b8 it dates
back to the second or third century AD
and like the other items in this room
was discovered in the ancient city of
Hatra southwest of Mosul
the antiquities of Hatra are significant
because they embody a fusion of ancient
cultures following the conquests of
Alexander the Great
they show how new trends in religion the
arts and other aspects of life spread
across the Arabian Peninsula here we see
a marble tablet from the 1st century AD
depicting Nergal the equivalent of the
Greek Hades god of the underworld
we are now in the Assyrian Hall Matthew
Vincente of project Mosul calls this
lion his favorite piece
it's a defiant creature symbolizing the
spirit of the project every time project
Mosul updates its photogrammetry system
this lion is used to test it
photogrammetry is a technique for
creating three-dimensional models using
photographs taken from different angles
it's becoming a common tool for the
preservation of cultural heritage one of
the main challenges and achievements of
project Mosul is its use of
crowd-sourced images taken by different
people at different times that were not
intended to be used for photogrammetry
take a quick look at the video screen in
the case of the wall relief you see here
video stills were used to reconstruct
the artifact since February 2015
thousands of photographs have been
uploaded to the project Mosul web site
by local people tourists and even
American soldiers who were deployed to
the area during the Iraq war
this collective participation is one of
the things that make project Mosul so
special
it's reconstructions provide an
opportunity for people to enjoy and
study these destroyed artifacts but the
advent of digital reconstruction
also raises questions about their
ownership and use and the extent to
which they can act as substitutes for
the originals
there are also worries that focusing on
artifacts risks diverting attention from
human suffering in conflict zones
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed your visit to the
virtual mosul museum a co-creation of
project mosul and the economist
[Music]
you
[Music]